الى لبنان حيث حتى على عقارب الساعه ينقسم
اللبنانيون فوصى ازمات اقتصاديه والسياسيه
استيقظ لبنان على توقيتين مختلفين اذ
اعتبر من اليوم وحتى العشرين من ابريل
المقبل سيعمل كل لبناني بالتوقيت الذي
يختاره او كما يختار حزبه او طائفته فيقرر
ان يبدا نهار اما بالتوقيت الشتوي او
الصيفي السجال بدا عندما طلب رئيس مجلس
النواب نبيه من رئيس حكومه التصريف
الاعمال نجيب ميقاتي تاخير العمل بتوقيت
الصيفيه العالمي مراعاه للصائمين خلال شهر
رمضان وهو ما لم يعجب احزاب ومكونات
مسيحيه اعترضت طبعا على القرار ورفضت
العمل به ما تسبب ببعض الارباك خصوصا على
قطاعات الاتصالات والطيران شركه طيران
الشرق الاوسط عدلت مواعيد رحلات المغادره
من مطار رفيق الحرير الدولي تماشيا طبعا
مع التوقيت الرسمي لكن هذا لم يعجب وسائل
الاعلام اللبنانيه التي دخلت الخلاف اذا
اعلن عدد منها العمل وفقد توقيت العالمي
نظرا لتداعيات مخالفه هذا القرار طبعا
تقنيا وانعكاساته السلبيه بحسب تلك
المؤسسات ومن بينها وكاله الانباء
اللبنانيه
[موسيقى]